Heat.
Heat. Heat. Heat.
Let's bring the man to the front. I don't think
we need an introduction. I began to listen to
this man 15 years ago when I became an SEA. Yes. I
started watching these videos online and I'm like,
who is this guy? where did he get this stuff
from? Like how does he how is he allowed to
say that stuff publicly, you know? So, and
I also heard the testimonies, the miracles,
and how the Lord protected him and some of the
things. And I'm like, the research was so deep
and it's pretty amazing. I made a Facebook post
about him coming. And when you read the chat is
like what the people are saying is I'm I'm a
Seventh Day Adventist today. I'm a Christian
today because of his because of his ministry and
what he has taught me and what I've learned over
the years. So these videos have gone far and
wide to reach so many people for Christ. So
without further ado, let's bring uh the man
to the channel at this time. Welcome to AMC,
Professor Walter V. How are you doing? I'm fine.
And you? Thank you so much. Thank you. We are
fine. Thank you for being here. We are excited to
have you. It's a pleasure. Wow. Yeah, no problem.
Without further ado, let's have a word of prayer
and get right into it. Loving father in heaven,
we thank you. We praise your name. Thank you for
the opportunity to talk and to hear, to listen, to
learn. Father, you said that to the multitude of
wisdom purposes are established. And we pray that
the wisdom that you've given to Walter Vice over
the years, Father, as an experienced minister, we
pray that wisdom will be shared with God's people
today that we may find encourage, encouragement,
strength, and the spiritual power that we need
to go forward in our journey of faith. Bless us
we pray. Take control of this internet, these
airwaves. Take control of these technologies
as well. use them as a conduit to minister to the
hearts of the people listening at this moment. It
is our prayer. We ask it all in Jesus name. Amen.
Amen. Amen. Amen. Was there any one particular 7th
day Adventist ministry or person that you can say
really helped you seal the deal in un recognizing
where the Bible was most was found to be accurate?
Well, I I came into contact with a carpenter who
was a a cabinet maker. So, he did built-in
kitchens and I was renovating my house at the
time. And he gave me a pamphlet which basically
just stated that uh the Roman Catholic Church had
changed the commandments of God. And he gave me
a pamphlet with three sets of commandments on it.
one from the Catholic catechism, one from the
Bible and one from the Lutheran catechism and both
the Lutheran and the Catholic one were different
from the biblical one. So that started the ball
rolling and he gave me uh some Bible studies.
We went right through the night the first time
he came to my house. We went through Daniel,
we went through Revelation in one night. So
we didn't even go to sleep basically. And from
then on I got involved with some of the people
in the church. And by the way in those days there
weren't really independent ministries within the
Adventist world. The message was being carried by
by the church and things have changed these days.
So Adventist uh independent ministries started
much later because some felt you know maybe not
enough is being done to spread this message. So
that's how it came about. So that individual was
very prominent in my early adventist experience.
Uh and then yeah then you had to learn the other
things sort of by the way I was baptized without
knowing anything about the spirit of prophecy.
In fact I had never heard until after I was
baptized of a name like let's say Ellen White
or something like that. Nobody uh gave me any
instruction on health reform or anything like
that. I just realized these people are weird.
They they eat grass. What's wrong with them?
So I had to learn that by myself. So I had some
interesting experiences. I was on a farm alone
and I just one day my wife and I looked at each
other and we were convinced you know the alcohol
that we are drinking. I had a huge bar in my house
and a whole cellar full of fancy wines and stuff
and I felt well this there's something wrong with
this. So we on our own decided we're not going to
we're not going to do this anymore. So what are we
going to do with this wine? Are we going to sell
it because you can get a good lot of money for
it? No. If you're not going to take it yourself,
why do you want to give it to someone else and
the Bible says this and the Bible says that? So,
I threw it down the toilet and we had a septic
tank and the septic tank packed up. It couldn't
handle the alcohol content. So, wow. We go. I
love it. Yeah. So, that's how that happened.
And then the same happened with, you know,
the carnivore diet that I was on. One day,
we just had this conviction. And then someone
phoned me and complained about uh the spirit of
prophecy and Ellen White and told me that I was in
a cult because of this stupidity of these writings
and I'd never heard of this woman. So I said to my
my wife, "Who's this lady that they're all talking
about?" And they had been a cult porter. They
brought me books, but I never read them. So I
was too busy. So we went to this book, these books
and a box that he had given us. And lo and behold,
I grabbed the first book that I grabbed
was called The Desire of Ages. And my wife,
shall I say, unfortunately, grabbed one
that was called Councils on Diets and Foods.
So that brought about a lot of turmoil in my
home. I could imagine. Now, how old was your
son during this transition? My youngest son, my
youngest son was about three years old when all
of this happened. So, he was able to Yes. flow
through not understanding what's happening to
mom and dad except for the becoming more gentle,
more kind, more loving, and all those great things
that come. My oldest My oldest one was about 12.
He took it quite hard because he was heavily into
sports and the school and uh all of those issues.
Yeah. So it was that very tumultuous time. Wow.
It's amazing. Yeah. It it can be very challenging
when we have young children. I heard you say in
the beginning that you had an argumentative spirit
and then I watched how through your testimony God
utilized that argumentative spirit. For instance,
when the priest was out shopping and this makes
no sense. So that argumentative spirit that was
probably used uh not in a positive way turned out
to be exactly what you needed to really utilize
your mind to understand the power of God and the
truth about God. So I think that I was a trained
scientist. So science has a scientific method and
there has to be a cause and effect and it has to
be somehow logical and I I wouldn't have been able
to embrace a religion that was not logical. So
strangely enough I was very involved in the oult
world which has absolutely no logic whatsoever but
that seemed to be fine at that stage. I don't know
how you put that together, but I'm glad that I now
have a a logical religion that clearly defines why
the world is in the mess that it is in. Clearly
defines the origin of the mess. Clearly defines
the solution for the mess. And nobody else
does that. The Bible does that immaculately.
it uh it gives the problem and it gives the
solution to the problem and the unfortunate
thing is most people don't want the solution sadly
you know Walter V you've also been uh having had
this conversion experience I also noticed the
nature of your ministry and some of the things
you've been preaching um I just want to you
know 249 WhatsApp prof has been going on it's
pretty amazing these episodes when you sit down
and listen. I don't know how you find the time
to put some of this stuff together. But anyway,
that's another discussion. Total Onslaught has
been life transformative for me and I can say the
same for some of our audience watch. You know,
could you get us could you give us a little bit
about the story behind that? How did you even
begin this? You were sharing with us backstage how
that happened. How did you get to the point where
you was like, okay, I'm gonna get their books and
I'm going to read from their books and I'm going
to expose all of these things and so that people
can understand what is really happening. What was
the motivation behind that? Well, for years I
had also been as I say involved in the new age
movement in occultism. I I read very avidly.
I read um Ellen a Bailey. I read Blavatzky's
writings. I read about Dual Cool. I read about all
of these issues. Uh then I also read a lot about
secret societies. I wasn't myself involved in
secret societies. I believe my father-in-law was.
And I had occasions when uh I had to assist him
with some things. And I met uh the top channels
of the of Africa for example. And what they showed
me that their communications are at a level where
they inform governments, where they inform health
ministries, where they inform sports bodies,
etc., etc. That was very fascinating to me.
and at very high levels and we're talking about
presidents. We're talking about prime ministers.
So I had that background and now I came into
contact with biblical truth and biblical prophecy
and I somehow had to reconcile and say okay what's
going on here? So I did a very deep study on this
and I had miraculous experiences with meeting
people and people coming to me and highmasons
and people from secret societies and people from
uh secret police for for example. And so all of
these issues came together and I started putting
together a series and that was about must have
been 38 years ago. And when I was invited for
the first time to go and preach in Europe,
I preached largely on science and evolution
versus the Bible. And I started preaching on the
health message. that didn't go down well because
u all the research that I was involved in sort
of was involved with you know plant-based diet
and the world wasn't quite ready for that so that
got me into a lot of trouble and then I gave two
lectures on the influence of the occult world on
on religion and how the two are antagonistically
orientated towards each other. And this was in
Germany and the German public and particularly the
German leadership in the church was hyperritical.
They didn't mind the evolution so much even though
I got a lot of flack from that as well from inside
and from outside. And then the the health message
didn't go down well because in how can you
propagate a a vegan diet? Nobody can live on
plant-based only. So there was 38 years ago there
was no such thing as going to a supermarket and
finding something healthy to eat. So the people
were sort of split. One totally for it and the
other one totally against it. It doesn't seem to
be there was a gray area. It was either you love
it or you hate it. And then I gave these two
lectures on my occult experiences and how they
sort of interact with religion and that caused
the nuclear explosion. And then people said,
"Okay, now now this is going too far. You have no
evidence for any of this and who who is Blavadski
in any case? Nobody's ever heard of this person.
And who's who's this and who is that?" and you're
talking about the United Nations and uh you're
talking about these organizations and you know
we're going to get in a lot of trouble with uh
with governments and we don't we don't need this
kind of stuff and you have no backing for your
theory. Will you please stop talking about that?
So I sort of got a gag order to stop preaching
about that. And I said, "But this is true." But,
you know, I didn't uh uh let's say quote many
of the sources. I was speaking off the top of my
head. And so, they said that there's no evidence.
So, I went back home to South Africa and I had two
options. either I keep quiet and say nothing or
I give so many quotes and so many references that
they drown in them. And so my two lectures
Yeah. So my two lectures ended up being 36
lectures with hundreds and hundreds and hundreds
of quotes. And then people started saying, "No,
all of these quotes don't exist." And they
started researching and then one bright
fellow after the other and one non-convinced
fellow after the other came back and they say,
you know, I checked this out and it really does
say that. I can't believe it. Is this really
true? And this is how it sort of developed.
And uh then they decided to give you know
rather the silent treatment and because they
knew every time they're going to say this is
not true they're going to get 36 instead
of two. So that's how it happened. Yeah.
Thank you so much for that. Very powerful. Very
very powerful. So now could we talk a little bit
about Bible prophecy because some of your studies
are very much prophetic in nature and uh in-depth
research. By the way, I really wish I could like
spend an hour in your library or maybe go to your
computer and just look at some of your archives
and I'm like, "Okay, what can I mess with? I'm a
book junkie, by the way." So, um I'm glad you
are. That's that's the only way that you're
going to unravel all of these things. You know,
like this guy says, "The only ones who believe in
conspiracy are those who've studied it." So,
and also the internet is like they're wiping
out a lot of things. A lot of materials are being
wiped away. Yes. There's like a fight on Wikipedia
right now. And I think there's a lot of Catholic
priests behind the scene that are reinterpreting
the historical record in ways that are very
troubling. So, we have to go to the books now
to get the stuff. If I can be blunt, then I can
say directly that the Jesuit counterreformation
movement is directly responsible for wiping
out most of the true history in this world.
The encyclopedias have been rewritten. The media
is under their control. You will hear what you are
supposed to hear. And so it's necessary to have
these things. And so I made very sure that I I
quote from the horse's mouth. I made very sure
that I get the books that you cannot buy and
I inherited a lot of them from my father-in-law.
But some of the deeper esoteric ones I got hold of
through miraculous means. In my testimony I speak
about some of those. So I actually have these
books. So then people want to argue. I ju I just
laugh at them because they just uh don't know. I
have the literature and I know what it says and
I know that Freemasonry is a luciferian religion
and I know that the philosophy of the United
Nations at its core is a luciferian philosophy.
So no matter how many Christians there are that
attend these organizations, they are not aware of
it because they're not in the inner circle and so
they won't know. So these are just issues that uh
you get from a lot of reading and reading from the
horse's mouth which I wouldn't recommend because
you're taken down a rabbit hole and you can become
fascinated with me. The reason why I could do it
is because I wasn't investigating into it to find
out what it said. I was investigating out of it
trying to find out why it's wrong because I was
there and I came out. I'm not I'm not a a true
blue little adventist who's trying to see what the
devil is saying. I don't suggest that for anyone.
So rather stay away from it and The quotes that I
give will be to corroborate biblical fact. So it's
not to peique the interest in the luciferian ways
but rather to make people aware of the pitfall and
the danger of that organization. Yes. Yeah. Wow.
Praise God for that counsel because I know many of
us feel like we're so behind and we need to try
to read everything and get a hold of different
books and understand it all. What is your what
would you say to those who are just, hey, I want
to get on track with Christ, be intentional. What
would you counsel them to do at this point? Well,
the Bible and the spirit of prophecy, you know, if
you only had those in your library, you'd probably
be a very wealthy man, spiritually speaking. Uh I
I don't particularly like reading things that um
filter what the Bible and the spirit of prophecy
say through some third entity or some theological
mind. I'd like to know what did God say? Give me a
direct translation. Please don't give me one that
has been filtered through some mind. And what does
the spirit of prophecy say? Don't tell me what it
says. Give me the quote so that I can go and check
it out myself. And that's that's what I like. And
you know what makes the Bible come alive for me
is typology. If you study the types in the Bible,
you cannot possibly be an infidel and you cannot
possibly not believe that God is the author of
that book. I mean the typological stories,
the depth of of the the typological meanings,
the the sin offering, the burnt offering, the
grain offering, the story of Adam going into
a deep sleep and then bringing forth, you know,
Eve. these old typo typologies of of the plan of
salvation and they're all so incredibly deep and
so so beautiful and so so well put together and
stretch over 1,500 years without a contradiction
that when you start studying them you realize this
is an inspired book. No human being could ever
ever have conjured up anything of that nature.
So I laugh at these people who think that the
Bible was put together by bearded men with
caveman experience. It's it's a ridiculous. They
read something like Paul. They don't understand
it and they want to give him a caveman experience.
I mean it's ridiculous. Watch the movies. How do
they depict John the Baptist? you know, like a
wild man like looking out that he just came out
of the tombs, let alone out of some some other
place. It's so funny you say that because I had
said that to my husband like these people don't
look right. No, they definitely don't look right.
They look pretty sad. Yeah, so true. I've studied
the Bible. I've studied the Quran. I've studied
the Vidic writings. I've studied the esoteric
writings. There's no book that you can read
50,000 times and read a book, read a new book
every time. There's only one that does that,
and that's the Bible. All the others,
you read them once, you read them twice,
you're bored. But this one is special. You will
find new things, new depths. Unbelievable. I mean,
silly stories in the Bible that you just sort
of gloss over. You know, somebody loses an axe
head and said, "My father, my father, I lost an
axe head. What am I going to do about it?" And
the thing was borrowed. I throw a stick in the
water and uh the thing will float. Yeah. I mean,
that's such a ridiculous story. Who's going to
believe that, right? Yeah. But an axe head is a
dead object. And whenever it was in the deep,
that means that it was lost forever. Because
you look at Christ, he will quote the Psalms
and he will say that the deep has covered him.
So whenever you were in the deep, you were in a
totally lost stage. So here there was something
that was physically dead. Act said it has no life
and it was in the deep. It was forever lost. And
it took a branch. And who is the branch? the
branch is Christ to put it into the water to
give something that is totally dead that doesn't
even have life to make it float and come to the
thing and it was borrowed because we all have a
borrowed life. I mean there's such depth in it.
If you if you start looking at it typologically
and you start studying these stories and you read
about Isaac and the wood being put on his back
and he's taken up the very mountain where Christ
was crucified and a substitute is found and the
whole plan of salvation is enacted in a person's
life. I mean how can you start denying the divine
inspiration of the Bible is just mindboggling.
mind. Amen. So the question and I had it too and
I saw it here. I fig I thought I was going to save
it till the end. So, did that young lady ever
find out that she was a catalyst? Some I think
it was either some 20 or 25 years later that uh
she to her great shock found out that this this
belligerent atheist had become a believer and she
actually contacted me and she was she's a young
lady. She was a young lady, Adventist lady, and
she'd moved to the United States, and she married
an Adventist pastor. So, yes, she did contact
me, and I could apologize for my for my actions,
making that young lady cry. It's awesome. What's
wrong with these professors nowadays? Um you must
understand you are dealing with uh the science of
this world. Have you ever can you imagine someone
like Dawkins or Hawkins or one of them being
told that their science is pathetic? How would
they react? And then still before students that
are supposed to feed from every word that appears
out of your mouth and their future depends on
it because they have to regurgitate it in an
exam. You can't allow this kind of disscent in
a classroom. So uh I'm not making an apology for
the way I acted but I had to defend science
against this this vile intrusion of a deity.
True. Yeah, that's the mentality. Um, today
there's a lot of prophetic events happening
and I'm I'm anxious to hear your thought. We have
the war in Iran. There is the esoteric stuff. You
talk about Alice A. Bailey. Uh, supposedly uh
I think what did she say the the hierarchical?
Yeah. The extermination externalization of the
hierarchy type of year that she made reference
to. She said in 2025. Yes. 2025 she made that
reference. So we're in 2026. So how much worse
is things now? So what are some things you see
happening prophetically that indicate from your
perspective that not only we are living in the
end times that like Ellen White says that the
final movements will be rapid ones? Well, actually
when you break it down into its basic components,
it's it's not that complicated because we are told
that a political entity who will enforce the mark
of the beast. So if a political entity and to all
uh the studies that we have it is pretty clear
that that political entity is the United States of
America. that rises at the right time in prophecy
and all of these issues. It has a lamblike uh
constitution. It speaks like a dragon that this
entity will enforce religious legislation which
for decades seemed highly improbable but now no
longer is improbable but highly probable and
uh forefront in the religious and political
thinking of that nation. And with the turmoil
of the the battle between the two mindsets of
secularism and religious morality, it's pretty
clear that if you look at the political figures,
whoever they are in the cabinet of Donald Trump,
for example, or in his military, that uh they
have an agenda and that is an an agenda to enforce
mor religious morality. And whenever you want to
enforce religious morality and they become pretty
blatant, I mean we had discussions with Wilson and
we had discussion with other entities where they
say that they want to legislate the first table
of the decalogue. Now where do you start with
legislating the first table of the decalogue? You
have to start with the fourth commandment because
you have to get the family together. You have to
have a synchronized day of worship and rest. You
have to have all of those things. And looking at
it prophetically, there is no doubt that they want
to legislate Sunday. And in order to do that, they
have to set up almost a dominionist system so that
religion can have a say again. and the speaker
of the house and all of these are saying that
separation of church is based on bad history, bad
interpretation of uh you know the founding fathers
etc etc. So that history is well on the way. Then
the next question is well if we're going to have
religious moral legislation then obviously how
are we going to deal with the different religions?
Our morality is not going to be the same as that
of although there are interconnections but it's
not going to be the same as the Jews. It's not
going to be the same as Islam. It's not going to
be the same as the atheist. So how we how we going
to regulate society? Well, how about we give each
religion its turf and each one can regulate it as
they want to. And in order to achieve that you
need some kind of accord. Now when it comes to
the the major religions then let's get an accord
together where we can all say all right we we have
similar origins we have similar ideals maybe
we can coexist. And that's where the Abrahamic
accord comes in. And if a nation now decides uh
it cannot be part of the Abrahamic accord to live
peacefully in coexistence with another religious
body or another mindset uh because you know for
whatever reason they have a superior origin
and they have a particular mission and that is
to wipe out all infidels and anybody who doesn't
agree with them. Well, that's not going to work.
So rather preemptively strike a mindset like that
and get rid of any idea that would disturb the
common good. So there have been so many statements
even out of the mouth of Donald Trump himself that
if this Iran issue comes to a close then hopefully
all those Islamic nations will have learned the
lesson and join the Abrahamic accord and then
they can all peacefully coexist. the Jews will
get their their turf and will be allowed to exist
in peace and with their religious norms in place.
The Islamic world will be able to do it in the
Christian world in the Christian environment.
And then there is one little group that says,
"Excuse me, we don't want it this way. We want
it differently. We don't want to keep a day that
is not honored by God, that hasn't been set aside
by God. And by the way, you cannot make the
eighth day, which you call the first day,
a rest day because God rested on the seventh day
and he honored and blessed the seventh day. So
that's what God said. We want to do what God said.
No, you can't do that in a Christian environment.
You have to keep the Sunday. You have to keep the
first day of the week. Excuse me. You're one day
too late. So there's a problem. And so they say,
"What do you want to be like the Jews?" And the
Jews say, "You're not allowed to keep the Sunday,
the the Sabbath like a Jew keeps the Sabbath
because that's only for the Jews." So you get the
death sentence in a Jewish environment, you get
the death sentence in a Christian environment,
you're between a rock and a hard place. That's
where we're going. And uh I believe it's happening
very rapidly. and the choice will come. Now,
all right. So, you're going to have to accept the
mark of the beast. The spirit of prophecy clearly
says that this battle unfolds in the Christian
world. It unfolds in the Christian world. Now,
some of the other religions like Islam for
example, they have Friday as their rest day,
but it's not a rest day because they only have a a
midday prayer session. Their stores are open until
that they close them for an hour and a half or
whatever and then they come back. Their real rest
day is in line with the world, their banking day
and all of these issues. Uh they are aligned with
the first day of the week and I think they will
be perfectly happy for the sake of the economy and
everything to have certain overlaps there. So even
the Jews for the sake of the economy will keep
certain things running uh and the orthodox will
have their their Sabbath etc. But a person that
wants to obey the commandments of God and hold to
the testimony of Jesus is going to be in a very
very difficult position. If you look at how they
are treating people that have a different mindset,
they are dispendable. just get rid of them,
blow them out of the water. So if you if
you're going to have a different mindset and
disturb the common good, then you better come
into line. I mean, we had that discussion
and they told us that in so many words,
it's better that you Adventists come over to the
first day of the week. No, sorry, not negotiable.
Um, it's interesting because I was looking
at that presentation you did here and um,
I mean that discussion you had with uh, Douglas
Wilson. Yes, Douglas Wilson. Yes. Yeah. It's very
interesting. Let me see if I could pull this up
very quickly. Um, some of the remarks that he made
about the seventh day advent is very interesting.
When you ask the question about can two walk
together except they be agreed? Yes. Yes. Is his
response isn't we see? But if we are a Christian
organization and a Christian nation, what if
there are differences in terms of worshiping
God within Christianity and the big issue of
course will be the issue of the Sabbath day.
So if there are blue laws and if blue laws are
propagated and then we'll have a juxtiposition
between the Sunday and the Sabbath and the
Christian denominations will say but that is
keeping a Jewish tradition but we will argue
that it comes from Genesis long before there
was a Jew. So it seems you stated on CNN that
when two walk together they should be agreed or
how can they walk together and you you stated
that in particular with the relation to Islam.
But what if Christians walk together and there
is a divide on which day to worship and if that
day should be legislated what would be the
consequence? Okay. So, um, what I would do,
one of the things you have to budget for is what
is the demographic composition of the Christians
in this Christian nation that you're building? If
the 7th Day Adventists are uh a an overwhelming
minority, then what's going to happen? If the
majority is thinking the way I'm thinking which
is in terms of mere Christendom which is very
different than detailed um detailed doctrinal
getting into details of doctrine. What you would
have is the stores would all close on Sunday and
Adventists would be allowed to close their their
stores on Saturday. There'd be no restriction of
uh of them. And then if you had adventists um uh
who worked for let's say uh first day sabotarians
you had adventists who were employees you would
have a struct the structure of the laws in such a
way as to be friendly to the adventists who wanted
to take uh Saturday off and have you know you ba
basically there's no re there's no reason to be
coercing anybody but the way it would go most of
the stores would close if most of the Christians
are first day are are first day observers. Um so
ba basically a mere christendom would have a high
degree of religious toleration for denominational
differences under those circles. Yeah, you and I
know where this is going. Uh I would like to hear
your thought because at least that's what he is
saying. Um and again this is just one man but we
know things doesn't always turn out to be that
way. Historically speaking, what will be wrong
with this clause, this exemption clause given to
the Adventist for their Sabbathke keeping? How how
things go completely uh off the rail? there will
be no exemption clause because he later on said
that you know it it is better to come in line with
the majority because there are so many bad issues
that need to be resolved and if one guy if one
group is pushing in another direction then bad
things can happen to them and uh he might be
tolerant but some of his brethren might not be
as tolerant as he and then of course they There
were other voices that clearly said that 7th day
Adventists don't even qualify. So they will just
have to buckle under and change their opinion or
else. So the Bible tells me which way it's going
to go. It's going to go to economic pressure and
then it's going to go to a death decree because
you you are just not reasonable. You are not you
are not working for the common good. you are not
working for a system of laws that have been set up
by a system which the Bible calls antichrist.
So that is a that is a very serious issue.
So I'm always surprised when I see even within
our own ranks people that believe, you know, that
Rome has changed and that we we should move away
from our outdated theology of the little horn and
changing times and laws and all of these issues.
And I think some very highplaced individuals
are of that mindset and they're going to get a
serious wakeup call because Rome never changes.
Wow. Praise God. It's um it's interesting that
people think that, but again, this is another
error. I published a video and what I've
entitled it was the true spirit of Romanism.
Let me show you because it it it looks
something like that. And what was going
on here was a Protestant that was talking to
a Roman Catholic. So is Ryan versus Ben. Ben
is the Catholic. But I want you to hear the
remark that came from this Catholic's mouth.
And it it it brings me right back to the great
controversies and what we've seen done to the
Protestant reformers of the time. And it's like
there is the spirit of Romanism on full display.
What we used to do with people like you is we
would interrogate you like this and then if you
continued in your obstinency, we would hand you
over to the civil authorities to root out the rot
that is caused by people like you. Repent of your
ways. You're a terrible terrible if you're not if
you if look you can just be dishonest if you
want. I just honest please be respectful. I've
been trying to show respect to you. I respect it.
I respect I respect God more than as somebody as
some you do a terrible job of cherrypicking. I've
already pointed out your picking. The Bible tells
us to show honor to right. It speaks about how,
you know, we should love one another. Should outdo
one another and show my love for you. My I love
you seem to be You don't seem to be wanting to do
this. You don't seem wanting to tell the truth.
Outdo one another and showing honor. That's what
my love for you says. Yes. Absolutely. Right. And
even if you think I was doing evil towards you,
the Bible tells you, don't repay evil for evil,
but give thought to do God by lying in the sight
of all. You're dishonoring God in possible
lying. So far, what we used to do with people
like you is we would interrogate you like this.
And then if you continued in your obstinency,
we would hand you over to the civil authorities
to root out the rot that is caused by people like
you. Repent of your ways. Wow. Repent. You don't
have self control. You're a sinner. You're a liar.
self control. You're a liar. Live peaceibly with
all. And yet, would you do you think that someone
like me who holds on to faith in Christ alone
to save me? Do you think I should be executed?
A liar. Do you think I should be executed? I think
you should be silenced if we live in a Christian.
Yes, you silence. Do you think you think I should
I should do you think I should be atheist? You're
an atheist more. And I would say this, you think I
should be burned at the state. You create atheist.
Wow. You know, when I when I've listened to
that and I want to hear your thought on it
while they're writing and we're going to take
some questions from the audience, I'm like,
isn't that the true spirit of Romanism? Isn't that
what we've read in history? Well, when you read
the paper in cyclicals, uh, you don't even have
to read the paper and cyclical. You can just watch
some of the speeches from the Heritage Foundation
where they have these very suave, very articulate
people. Uh I I sort of spot them a mile away that
they're Jesuit trained. They probably attended
Georgetown University or Fordam University or one
of those. They are so steeped in knowledge as to
uh the views of uh Thomas Ainus of Augustine
and all of these individuals. And you read a
papal encyclical they will quote Thomas Ainus
from here from there from every aspect and they
will call him the holy honorable doctor and this
and that. But his his opinion is no different from
that belligerent fellow that we just listened to.
And you know that that tree has to be pruned and
that individual that has this uh dastedly mindset
will have to be eradicated like a cancer in order
to save the common mindset. So that is a very
very common issue and that's where it's going
to go and that's the kind of attitude that we will
be dealing with probably on a little bit more of
a a intellectual level mingled with a sort of
appearance of sadness but really no sadness
whatsoever and a very educated environment that
we're going to deal with. So yes, these people
think like that. And unfortunately, the Protestant
world has become such that it thinks just like
that. Yeah. Mhm. Yeah. Wow. They've become like
the the Catholics themselves. So let's take some
questions from the audience here. Um we going to
begin with Duran's question here. Can you explain
what Israel and the Zionism movement has to do
with the prophecy or with laws of USA? All right,
let's can I be very blunt? I I think the time
for you know approaching this like a chameleon
is over. Zionism is a political movement.
Zionism is not a religious movement at all.
Although it is claimed that it is a religious
movement, Zionism is a political movement to
set up a political state and uh ultimate Zionism
is to expand the the state to the point where the
Old Testament says that God gave this land to to
Israel. Um, Israel today is a Masonic construct.
Israel is not a a god- driven movement because
it is a Masonic construct and it it derives
from a Jesuit theology and all the nations were
partakers in this issue. This decision uh was
made probably long time ago and the idea is to
set up a Jewish state where the Jews could again
uh rule. Now I I am I am not an anti-semite. I've
been accused of being an anti-semite because I say
things that such as if you are in Christ you are
Abraham's seed and hes according to the promise
which is a Bible verse and I can quote the spirit
of prophecy which says that as a nation they are
forever forsaken of God because they have rejected
the Messiah but not as a people. As a people,
they have the scriptures at their disposal.
They have the richness of the Old Testament.
They can make a decision to accept Christ as their
personal savior. And even some of the messianic
Jewish movements of today that accept Christ don't
accept him as we accept him. They accept him as a
national deliverer. No, he's not a national
deliverer. He's an He's a deliverer of those
that believe in him. Because the Bible has a very
strong word which says whosoever. It doesn't talk
about a political entity or a a racial entity.
The word is whosoever. Whosoever believeth in him.
And uh as a as a nation if they are forever
forsaken of God and some people will say how
can how can the spirit of prophecy or how can
Ellen White make such a harsh statement? Well,
what does it mean? Your house has been left to you
desolate. Not one stone will be left upon another.
And then the Jewish nation was dispersed and
the great destruction of Jerusalem in 70 AD
and even greater destruction under the emperor
Hadrian where dispersed the whole Jewish nation.
Then the whole history of the rise of Islam and
the crusades which were a movement basically to
uh exert Christian superiority over the over the
holy holy land and the holy areas. So you have all
of these holy places there. There's only one holy
place and that's where Christ is present and that
will be where two or three come together in his
name. No pilgrimage is necessary. None of that
is necessary. It's useful in terms of archaeology
to get some corroboration of what happened there
in biblical times. But as a nation, they are
forever forsaken of God. So the whole nation,
whole issue of Zionism is not something that you
find in the Bible. There's no two uh double plan
for the Christians and another one for the Jews.
There are no two dispensations. There are no
two brides. There is one bride. You're either in
Christ or you are not in Christ. That's the bride.
So, Zionism is a political construct and it is
driven by Masonic ideas and it is to get those
that have rejected Christ as their personal savior
to come together in a Jewish nation where they can
reestablish their temple where not one stone
was to be upon another because the temple that
is built is a spiritual temple and everybody body
that accepts Christ is grafted into that temple as
a living stone. Peter makes that quite clear. You
are living stones that are built into a spiritual
house. That is the temple of God that is being
built right now. To build a temple of stone again
is a blasphemy. It's a denial of the atonement.
It's a denial of what Christ did. And that is what
uh this situation is all about. And then you have
the Orthodox who say they will not accept Christ.
As one of their Sanhedrin members said, "We prefer
to go to Awitz rather than to accept Christ."
Well, I'm terribly sorry, my friend, but if you
reject Christ, you are rejecting the only wing
that you can hide unto in the under in the time of
trouble. So the Jewish nation is a is a political
uh Roman Catholic secret society construct that
has as a biblical value other than a diversion
from the truth no value. That's pretty blunt
but that's how it is. That's how I understand
it as well. Thank you. Thank you for that
response. Okay. Our next question comes from JC
Forshaw 8221. Will I be saved if I follow the ten
commandments? Repent, keep the Sabbath, Saturday,
and I get cremated. Is that okay, or do I need to
be buried? All right. Uh, you will not be saved by
keeping the ten commandments, but you will not be
saved by ignoring them either. So the question is,
why do you want to keep the ten commandments? It's
because you love him. Because he redeemed you from
the state that you were in and he convinced you
that these principles are the most logical ways
in which to order a society so that sin will
never raise its head again. So I keep the clean
commandments because Christ convinced me that
that form of government is one that I want to
abide under. It'll be wonderful if I never have to
put a lock on my car or a lock on my door where I
can walk the streets. Where a lady and my wife
would be safe no matter in what dark alley she
walks. Where nobody lies to you, nobody cheats,
nobody wants to kill you. Where people honor you
because of you are a parent or whatever and the
fifth four commandments are all pertaining to God.
What a society that would be. I I I would endorse
such a such a how do you call it a white writing
statutary law of any society. So that's that's the
society that I would like to live under and the
one who presides over it is a king and his name is
Jesus. So that's the one king that I would honor
because he will do it because he loves me and
not because he wants to coersse me or force me.
So that's why I keep the ten commandments.
Not because I it gives me a passage to heaven,
but because I accept the government as God has
proclaimed it because it's logical and it makes
sense to me. So having said that, what if I am
cremated? Well, then I'm afraid you're in big
trouble because God can't find you anymore. You're
all over the place. No, I'm really joking. Sorry.
That that's a Catholic mindset. I mean, let's take
uh Wickliffe, the morning star of the Reformation.
Yeah. Uh he he died a natural death, although they
really wanted to burn him at the stake. And then
at the Council of Constants, when they finally got
rid of one of his his students who was Yan Husse,
uh they decided to burn Hus at the stake for his
heresies. And they realized that his heresies came
from the writings of Wikliffe. So they decided
to dig him up and to burn his bones, grind them
to powder, and throw them in the river swift. And
that should get rid of it forever and ever. And
every so-called heretic that has been burnt at the
stake to ashes will be lost if that philosophy of
cremation were true. That God can't find you.
God is not dependent on the the anatomy that
you have at the moment of your death in order to
reconstruct you. By the way, uh every 8 years or
so, you are a body consisting of totally replaced
molecules. So, which molecules is he going to use
to reconstruct you? Those that when you were young
or those when you were old when you've switched
them over some eight or 10 times already? No. No,
no, no. God is not dependent upon your physical
uh anatomy and your physical composition in order
to reconstruct you. He has you on his hard drive.
He has your character, your mode of thinking.
He knows everything about it. And by the way,
you're getting a better body. The spare parts
that he comes with don't even compare to to
what we have now, which is pretty miserable.
So I hope he doesn't construct me of the mess
I'm consisting of right now. I will get a new body
and amen that that God can do just by speaking the
word. But the blueprint of who you are that will
be instilled in you. Your character and that which
is your your basis of your faith and your belief
system that'll go through and that'll be you.
Amen. Amen. That was beautiful. Yeah. Powerful.
Appreciate that. That was so good. All right. We
do have another question from Duran here. Uh, can
you tell me something about the Holy Spirit? I've
been struggling with the Trinity doctrine since a
very close friend of mine have shown me the text
that suggest uh the question I'm going to keep
reading. It suggests it's not God. Hm. I do not
want to sin by rejecting our doctrine about that
topic that topic. But the indoctrination that has
I'm sorry but the information that he has is
highly credible and more when I when he talk
about the baptism certification before and what
says now. All right, James, I remember that you
had a program, correct me if I'm wrong, with Randy
SK, on the Trinity and you said you're not going
to argue about this issue anymore. This is what
you believe. Take it or leave it. And uh don't
don't come with any counter arguments. Is that
correct? Is that in a nutshell what happened at
that particular one? Yeah. Yeah. Okay. All right.
Was the Holy Spirit mentioned in Genesis chapter
one? Absolutely. Yep. Yes. The spirit hovered over
the water, right? Was the Holy Spirit mentioned in
um the baptism of Jesus? There was a voice from
heaven. That was the father. There was the son. He
just came out of the water. And then there was the
spirit that came down upon him. Right. Yeah. So,
they were all three there. Then I counseledled to
you to buy from me gold refined in the fire and
white robes and I solve. Isn't that the message
to the Lotus? Mhm. So the gold is representing
the character of the godhead which is embodied in
the father. The white robe is embodied in Christ.
Where you get the eyesolve from? What opens
your mind to the understanding? Isn't that the
holy spirit? Mhm. You know, you have all of these
beautiful things in the Bible and the Holy Spirit
uh convicts of sin and righteousness and judgment
and he testifies of Christ. So if if I were to
testify of someone, then I don't become that
someone. I'm a representative. Uh I I don't
present Christ. I represent him. I'm just a a
voice here crying in the wilderness. So as to
the deity of of those three entities, if you do a
serious Bible study, then you will find that all
three of them qualify for that name Yave. And uh
I don't want to go into the doctrine of the of the
trinity now because you're going to get a million
emails telling that you know we're off the wall
and all of that sort of stuff. But uh if you want
to be consistent and there is only one that is God
and it has to be the father then the two others
must be in some way generated or created. And
uh you know they say no not created begotten but
begotten means monogan one of a kind the unique
one in whom dwelt all the fullness of the godhead
bodily in him was life unborrowed underived. What
does that mean? And uh if you take Catholic
doctrine then Christ was generated and the only
the holy spirit was breathed into existence. So
they are secondary. No, they were there from the
beginning before Abraham was. I am. I lay down
my life and I take it up again. I no one takes
it from me. And you read uh John chapter one and
it says in him was life. And Ellen White adds the
word unborrowed, underived, but it's so clearly
depicted there. And this life was the light of
the world. and the light shone in darkness and the
darkness comprehended it not. One of the very sad
verses in the Bible. You know what? I'm I'm at the
point where you are. That's what I believe. If you
don't want to believe it, you're welcome to it.
But that's the fact of the matter. The Holy Spirit
is as much God as he is uh as is Jesus Christ
as is the father. And they are one in purpose.
The word used there in in Genesis chapter one
is a plurality. Elohim created. And Elohim is
not a singular. It's a plural. Let us make man in
our image. Who's he talking to? The Jewish rabbi
say he's talking to the angels. Excuse me. The
angels can't create. Let us make man. It has to
be someone else that he's talking to. He's talking
to the son. And the son actually spoke the words
and created everything. By him were all things
created and without him was not anything made that
was made. I mean how clear do you want to get? In
him dwelt all the fullness of the godhead bodily.
I don't want to talk to these people anymore about
the issue. If you don't want to believe it, go for
it. If you want to believe the Catholic version
that he was a generated version, go for it. But
he had life unbared, unerived, that's why he could
lay it down. That's why he could take it up and
that's why he can give it to me. And my hope is
is in him that his voice will resurrect me. Yeah.
Amen. Amen. Amen. That's powerful stuff. I you
know when you speak you can see that the word is
just embedded within your spirit within your soul.
It's just the very nature of the the new nature,
the the power of God really rests in how you
articulate and you share what God has given
to you. And I think that's something that we all
can take in and recognize that that is where we
need to be. We need to be studying our word.
We can tell that you are a man of deep study.
That's kind of you. That's kind of you. I can say
there are two things that bother me. There are two
things that bother me. Anybody who wants to make
Christ less that he is or anybody who wants to
make himself equal to him. Those two things bother
me. Praise God. And we just need to study and to
show oursel approved. And what you said, the Holy
Spirit will reveal himself. We are going to hear
so many people trying to convince us that the word
of God is not true, trying to provoke us to doubt
and to question the authority of the word of God.
And we need to stand on our belief and know why
we believe what we believe and that comes with a
deep study of the word of God and additionally the
spirit of God. Exactly. Man doesn't live by bread
alone but by every word that proceeds out of the
mouth of the Lord. That's why I want a translation
that gives me the exact words that Jesus spoke or
that the Holy Spirit spoke to the entities that
wrote it down in their own words. But uh I want
to have a direct translation. I want to know what
God says. And if God said it, I believe it and
that's it. Because any doubt that I've had over
my 39 years as a Christian has been overwhelmingly
buried by the beauty of truth presented in in any
form. Were there ever times when I had doubts?
Of course, there were times when I had doubts.
Were there times when I questioned verses in the
Bible or the spirit of prophecy? Of course,
I wouldn't be human if I didn't have those.
But I made it a point not to make my doubts
public until I was convinced that they were
either wrong or not wrong. And sometimes for
for years I wouldn't get an answer. And then
out of the blue something would strike you like
a thunderbolt. This is what I've been looking for
for three years. And if that happens to you 100,
200, 300 times eventually you say I capitulate. I
accept every word as the word of God. I have never
ever in my entire Christian experience been right
in an argument with God. I've always lost and he's
always won and that's the way it's going to stay.
So true. So true. Amen. We do have a question
from Rebecca 7777. uh were the dinosaurs on
Noah's ark and what were the animals that were
that was amalgamagated man and beast that sister
right sister white wrote about okay that's a
very common question well dinosaurs do we find
dinosaurs depicted on cave drawings do we find
them on ika stones do we find them in absolutely
normal societies that lived post flood like the
Incas and all of those, the answer is yes. They're
all over the place. And uh if you read the legends
of of dragons and fiery creatures and all of these
creatures that you read about, some of them are
in a totally historic setting with no mythology
attached to them whatsoever. So yes, I believe
that some of these creatures were on the ark and
that some of them have been hunted to extinction.
Uh nobody would have believed that lions existed
in the Middle East or in Babylon until the the
the Ishtar gate was discovered and you see all
these lions and all these reliefs of the Assyrians
uh going on a lion hunt and well they don't exist
there now. That doesn't mean they didn't exist
in the past. The same for the dinosaurs. So what
are these amalgamated creatures? Well, if you
look at that sentence in the spirit of prophecy
from a grammatic aspect, then it talks about
amalgamation of beast and amalgamation of man and
not necessarily amalgamation of man with beast.
So what were the amalgamated creatures? I have a
pretty um sneaky suspicion that the amalgamated
beasts were the mammallike reptiles. Now the the
animal kingdom is divided into huge categories
of animals and you have amongst the vertebrates
you have the the fishes and then you have the
amphibians and then you have the reptiles and
then you have the mammals. So you have a very
clear distinction today anatomically between a
reptile and a mammal. Whereas in the past there
was a third category a vast category as large
as any of the reptile or mamalian categories which
were called the mammallike reptiles. And they were
sort of halfway in between their skull structure
and everything was halfway in between that of a
mammal and that of a of a reptile. Now that whole
category of animals is gone. It's only found in
the paleontological record. So why is there
no evidence of any of those creatures having
survived? And they're pretty odd creatures having
survived. Well, they they weren't on the ark. So I
believe that they were the confused species. And
I believe that the Antilovians were brilliant.
They were of such scientifically advanced um
science that we look like cavemen compared to
them. So those people who believe that you know
the the antidoluvians were cave dwellers well they
better think again. They probably had a better
technology than anything that we have. And what
testifies to that? There's something called oop
art, out of place artifacts and uh we find them
all over the place and nobody knows what they are
and some of them are so technically advanced that
you don't know what to do with them so you shove
them in some museum drawer. So yes, they were
highly advanced and they probably did have gene
technology just like we have gene technology. And
uh where are they today? Well, what is the what
does Atlantis tell us? That they disappeared
under the ocean. Where's the greatest evidence
for the flood? Under the Pacific Ocean. That's
where you have the greatest canyons, the greatest
uh evidences of a a watery um catastrophe. So,
we're probably driving our cars with them. They're
probably part of the oil fields and the organic
matter that we are extracting from the earth.
So, yes, they were a highly advanced race and
I've read a lot about some of those those issues
and the hidden archaeologies behind all of these
things and very advanced race. So they they
did have amalgamation and they probably also
amalgamated animals with humans and that we've
done that in today's world. I mean we put the
human genes into tomatoes. So if we can do that
we can surely do it in the other way around as
well. And one of the reasons according to the
spirit of prophecy why God brought about the
flood is because of these experiments that they
did. And if you look how far down the line we are
in that despicable road, then there's no reason
why God shouldn't destroy this world in the very
near future. Long answer. Sorry. Great answer. We
appreciate your wisdom and sharing all that you
have. Our next question and I know we are watching
the time here. Um it comes from Dixada. She says,
"I have heard that we are not allowed to wear
wigs or braid our hair, but I have alopecia
which affects my confidence as a woman. Will I be
cast out of heaven because of wearing a wig?" It's
very personal. Yes, that's a personal question. My
heart goes out to you. Let me put it this way. The
Bible says the women of Zion are haughty. So, the
issue is why are you doing something? What is the
reason why you are doing it? Uh my favorite one is
that some of these Israelite ladies were mincing.
I sort of amused at that picture that it conjures
up. You know that that lady walk where you sort
of wiggle your behind in a particular way and
the jingling of the of the this and the that it
is haughtiness. It has nothing to do with the
situation that you are talking about. And you
know some some people have naturally curling
hair or will they be excluded from heaven? No,
it's about what happens in the heart. And uh
this is the issue. And if you have a certain
condition or if uh for some reason you might
have had uh some chemical treatment like chemo
or something like that and you lose your hair uh
then it is absolutely perfectly fine to augment
uh what you have lost as long as it doesn't make
you haughty and make you superior to others. It's
what happens in the heart, not what happens on the
outside. So the the suggestion is that you dress
neatly and don't run ahead of the fashion. Don't
be so far behind the fashion that you look like an
idiot. Uh use your common sense and be modest
and have a an open heart to to what is right
and what is what is wrong. So the issues that
you are talking about will certainly not exclude
you from heaven. Thank you and thank you for your
vulnerability with that question. A lot of people
have questions about those adornments or those
things and as you said it's a matter of the heart.
Yeah. So is Islam based on the first of the two
witnesses mentioned in the Bible? So I'm guessing
that's Revelation 11. Well, what are the two
witnesses? They are the the olive. They are the
oil from the olive. And uh if you read in the Old
Testament, they what are they? This is the word of
God. So what two divisions of the word of God do
we have? Isn't it the Old and the New Testament?
So those are the two olive branches. And those
are the two witnesses. And these witnesses have
to be silenced. they have to be silenced because
uh they expose the hypocrisy and the twisting and
the false theologies of those that practice them.
So those are the two olive branches. So Islam is
it based on the two witnesses? Well, Islam is
based on the antithesis of the two witnesses.
The greatest antithesis is that Islam denies
the atonement of Jesus Christ. Christ never died
for you. And uh Christianity, well, Protestants
believe that the blood of the lamb is what saves
you, that Christ died for you and bore your sins.
Catholicism teaches that you bear your own sins
and pay for them in a place called purgatory.
So purgatory is the denial of the atonement.
And the Jesuit theologians directly tell you that
they don't believe in the atonement. Christ dies
as the perfect sacrifice and the perfect example,
but he didn't die for you. You have to pay for
your own sins and that's why you go to purgatory
unless you can get an adult indulgence from the
pope. So maybe you should watch his tweets. I'm
being a little bit fitus here, but that's how it
is. So Islam denies the atonement. It denies
the the deity of Christ. denies the sunship
of Christ and therefore it is not in harmony with
the two witnesses just like Catholicism is not in
harmony with the two witnesses and uh that would
be my answer. Amen. Amen. Praise God. All right,
we want to kind of mess with you for a few more
minutes here and then uh we're definitely going
to let you go. What is the significance
of Iran Israel USA warning to us today?
All right. As I said in a in a previous lecture,
Iran are Shia Muslims and they believe that their
moolas, their clergy, their leading clergy are
from the direct genealogical line from Muhammad.
Therefore, they are the ultimate authority in
terms of interpreting Islamic law and Islamic
structure such as Sharia for example. So the rest
of the world is or the largest portion of the
Islamic world is Sunni which doesn't necessarily
say that you have to have this direct line.
So the likelihood of you becoming more of a
fanatically militant Islamist is if you were
from the Shia line. Now most of the people in
Iran are actually secular. They're they're not
really that religious. It's a minority that is in
control just like in Israel. I mean secularism is
the norm. If you go to any of the the coastal
cities, you will see that you will find very
little difference between the behavior of uh
those living in Israel to those living, let's say,
in California. There's no there no difference.
So, uh yes. So this kind of thinking that you
have a direct line and that you are saved because
of your genealogy is one that is inherent in many
religions. Doesn't Judaism believe that because
they are of the line of Judah that they are the
true inheritors and and even that is questioned
today. The Jews today aren't necessarily all
from that particular line. They come from a
lot of lines that have nothing to do with the
uh original Semites. But that be that as it
may, any religion that claims that it has the
ultimate and the only way that is correct is a a
an affront to those that want to live in harmony
in an ecommenical environment. So you have to set
aside your doctrine and that is why uh all the
popes including Pope Francis has consistently said
that we cannot base our society on doctrine. We
have to base it on tradition and where we overlap.
So set aside doctrine. Now the reformers always
said you cannot set aside doctrine because the
moment you set it aside you crucify Christ again.
So, uh, take heed of the doctrine, takes the BI,
says the Bible. The papacy says, do not take heed
of the doctrine. Whom am I supposed to believe?
Obviously, I'm going to go with take heed of the
doctrine and I'm going to ignore the usurper who
says don't take heed of the doctrine. And the same
with with Iran. So Iran being above a step above
higher in their ideology and in their lineage
they cannot conform to this because they are the
ultimate standard. So you have to get rid of them
just like you'll have to get rid of the sabotarian
Christians because they're saying that their way
is right and everybody else is wrong. That's not
for the common good. You have to get rid of those
people. They are belligerent. They are disturbers
of society. They are troublers of Israel. They
have to go. And this is the issue. So this war is
to get rid of that particular mindset. And to let
that mindset understand that if you don't knuckle
under to the common good, the only route open to
you is elimination. That's it. This is a religious
war. Everybody in a position of authority in the
Trump government has publicly acclaimed that it is
a religious war. Wow. Goodness. Okay. Uh I guess
this question could be a followup to that. Did
the Catholic Church start Islamic religion? Thank
you in advance. All right. Now, if you if you say
yes to that question, you're likely to be banned.
particular I had a I had a lecture once which
was called the Islamic connection where I tried
to show that that was indeed the case. If you
look at all of their core doctrines and how they
coincide and I recently had a discussion on Islam
together with Martin where we spoke to Shabaz who
comes from a Shia Muslim background and uh we
had so much backlash with from within the church
because there are people within our church that
claim that Allah is the same God that we serve.
Now I beg to differ with them. They might be
in ecumenical councils and they might have high
positions within our church. That doesn't bother
me at all. They can have that position if they
want to. But uh my God had a son and that son is
called Jesus Christ and that son died for me and
that son is the one who's going to resurrect
me and that son is God in the flesh. when he
was down here on this earth and I'm not going to
give up that God. And if Islam denies that God,
then it's not then he's not my God. Then he has
the same doctrines when it comes to the doctrine
of hell. He just uh embellishes on Dante's Inferno
and makes it a little bit worse. He has an angel
dragging you across burning coals, throwing you
into hell, burning your skin off every day so that
you can feel the pain in you when he gives you
a new skin the next morning. giving you a brass
drink to drink from a fruit that burns your guts
out so that you can have the same pain of getting
a new gut and burning it out again. I mean, what
kind of deity is that? I don't have a deity like
that. He's not in the Bible and I don't serve a
deity like that. Therefore, Allah is not my God
and I have no beef if they want to worship that
God. I have no beef, whatever god they want to
worship. But I would invite them to find out who
my God is. Who loved so loved the world that he
gave his only begotten son that whosoever should
believe in him should not perish. That is the God
that I serve. That makes no distinction between
male and female, black and white or whatever race
or creed you come from. Whoever accepts him
is accepted with him and uh his kingdom will
be an everlasting kingdom. I would invite every
Muslim to become a Christian, but a true Christian
keeping the commandments of God and having having
the faith of Jesus. Amen. Goodness. This is uh
Yeah, I feel like this one struck a chord in you
because you said it earlier whenever Jesus is
either being demoted or anybody's trying to take
their place, you know, the mystery of godliness
and the mystery of iniquity. Well, if I was if I
went behind the scenes, I could uh testify that
I've been called into many a Sanhedrin council and
being told that I must uh eat my words. With the
last one, I received a letter again from someone
who said they're going to make lectures against
this because Allah is the same God that we serve.
These people are welcome to believe what they
believe. They are very high up in our leadership
position, some of them. But that doesn't make the
whole leadership apostate because there are many
that don't believe it, but they're just not as
vocal about it. Now, if they want to believe that,
and if they want to teach that Allah is the same
God as my God, they're welcome to believe that.
I'm not going to stop them, but they're certainly
not going to change my mind because uh I know what
the Bible teaches and that's what I'm going to
stick to. And if it takes if it takes a a wrapping
over the knuckles every now and then, so be it.
Yeah, the the chat the chat is on fire with
some amens after that response. Oh, yeah. Um,
praise the Lord. I don't know how many other
questions. How much more trouble you want to
get into? You really want to continue with
this? Listen, we're here. We we listen,
you can get in as much trouble as you want here
because I see it says unapologetically unorthodox.
You can interpret that however you want.
All right. I'm taking it I'm taking it as
it stands there. Amen. Amen. There's been a lot of
discussion about this one. I think this is a good
question. Some people are arguing that the seal
of God is the Holy Spirit. It's not the Sabbath.
So could we say that the seal of God is the seal
of truth? This person is asking. The seal of God
is being so settled in the truth that you cannot
be moved and there are only three definitions of
truth. And that is Jesus is the way, the truth
and the life. Thy word is truth and the law and
all thy commandments are truth. Those are
the three definitions. So being settled in
the truth is you're not going to be moved on the
divinity of Christ. You're not going to be moved
on the validity of the word and you are not going
to be moved on the commandments of God which is
the basis of his government. That's what it means
to be sealed by the Holy Spirit. Amen. Amen. That
was actually the best I've ever heard in a way
that is interpreted because often time we go
through we talk about the the the Sabbath which
is definitely truth in the light of the word
uh the law of God. Of course, it is the seal
of the of the commandments. It is the one that
where you acknowledge him as your creator and
your redeemer and you acknowledge him as your
king. Because if you acknowledge him as your king,
then you're going to keep his commandments. Okay.
All right. Take the next question. All right. So,
question regarding the entanglements of the church
and the UN. Does Walter that this connection has
no consequences for the members as a whole? That
is that all the members must bear the dot dot
dot dot dot dot. All right, let me I I just
answered that question on a stage in Australia
just recently and I got a lot of flack and a lot
of uh messages telling me, you know, I was I was
off the wall on this one and uh but I will state
it again because I I really believe that uh
what I'm going to say is how it is. So let me
go for it. Uh what is my position on the United
Nations? Well, go to title onslaugh. There's a
lecture called the UN and the occult agenda that
puts it pretty plainly and bluntly that the United
Nations philosophy is a luciferian philosophy
based on the writings of Plavatsky and Alis
Alice A. Bailey embellished and driven by uh the
Jesuits like Pier Tylot the Shadin and others who
the Catholic Church apparently wants to distance
itself from without distancing themselves from him
because once a Jesuit always a Jesuit he's just
said it plainly what they want to say uh secretly.
So that's the philosophy of the United Nations.
It is not an organization that furthers the
truth. The largest representation is the bahigh
which is an ecumenical organization and I know
how the United Nations were formed and what the
forerunners of the United Nations were and all of
those people were together with Charles Darin for
example, prime ministers of the UK etc. They were
in organizations like the ghostly guild. They were
spiritists. They were not representatives of Jesus
Christ no matter what they say. That's my position
on the United Nations. Now, what's my position on,
let's say, echanism? My position on echmenism is
what has light and darkness got in common? I don't
believe our church should be in the ecumenical
council. Is it in the ecumenical council? Well,
many of our organizations are in the ecumenical
council and u I have crossed swords with these
individuals. I've been banned in certain countries
because I go against them. I have been accused by
leaders in the ecumenical council from our own
denomination at government level. I have been
charged on issues of that nature. So uh I'm not
very um popular in those circles because I say
that uh what has light and darkness got in common
and you you can't be in an ecumenical council. Can
you be observing what they do? Of course you have
to study that. And I myself was sent, you know,
to a ecumenical meeting as a representative
of our church. And they asked in that meeting,
it was one held in a big senate building. And
they asked in that meeting who would be in favor
of legislating morality in this country. This was
now in South Africa. And every single hand shot up
bar mine. And they looked at me like I was, you
know, from another planet. Where where did you
drop out now? And they asked me, "So, what's
your position?" And I said to him, you know,
I've been sent by my church to come and hear what
you have to say. I I cannot vote on an issue on
behalf of my church without my church having made
a decision on this issue. I can't do that. So,
I'm not going to vote. I'm here to listen and to
observe what you are saying, but let me ask you
a question. And then I asked them the obvious
question. If you're going to legislate Sunday
and I refuse to keep it, what are you going to
do? And they said to me, um, if you are part of
our organization, we might be able to protect
you, but not if you are not, then no. Well,
I don't need their protection because I have a
much better protection. All right? So, let me
put that aside. I don't mind sitting in a council
and listening to what these people have to say,
but to join their society and join their decision
making and doing all of that, that is going far
and beyond what the scripture tells us. That is
whoring with the [__] of Babylon. So I can't
be more plain than that. Now did my church and I
said this in Australia as well. Did my church at a
general conference in session decide that we are
going to be part of the United Nations? And the
answer is what? No. There was no such decision.
Did certain people in high places or maybe even
certain committees or what no matter at what level
did they decide to do this by a a vote? And the
answer is probably yes because they are involved
in that. Well, that's their problem. So now what
do I do about it? Do I leave my church because
somebody in a committee decided something that
I believe was non-biblical? And let me be quite
blunt. I think there were decisions by committees,
let's say during the co period that were not in
the interests of God's people. Am I going to leave
my church because a committee decided that? The
answer is no. I'm not going to leave my church
because there's coming a shaking. And who's going
to do the shaking? It's not me. It's the straight
testimony that's going to do the shaking. And the
spewing out comes out of the mouth of Jesus. He
will spew out who is not supposed to be here. And
the spirit of prophecy makes it quite clear and
says if there is adjustment that is needed at the
top, God will see to it. Now our problem is that
you know he's asleep in the boat. Hello Jesus.
Why are you sleeping in the boat? Don't you see
the storm that's raging around us? Will you please
wake up? We perish and you're doing nothing about
it. Well, God's time is not our time. Sometimes
he lets something ripen to the point of rottness
before he intervenes. I don't believe we should be
in the United Nations. I don't believe we should
be in the in the ecumenical councils. But if
some people in high position made those made
those things and they ban me which is the case
then doesn't stop me from speaking. I was in in
a country in Europe and the president phoned me
and said uh what are you doing? Don't you know
that you are banned? I said yeah I'm banned in
the churches. I'm not banned from speaking in a
hall or coming to this country. But what are you
going to speak about? I said if you want to know
come and listen. You're not going to stop me from
speaking in a hall and Amen. Yeah. So, this is
the position. God will God will do the adjusting.
God will take care of it. Let us weep between the
porch and the altar for all the evil that is done
in Israel. And let's hope that there is a good
outcome rather than a bad outcome. Let's hope that
some people will see the light and uh do what is
right in the eyes of the Lord. And yes, that's not
my problem. This is really God's problem. As long
as my church as a body at the general conference
in session has not decided that we are part of
these bodies and they have publicly stated that we
are not part of the ecumenical council even though
some of our leaders are actually chairpersons
of ecumenical councils. That's their problem.
My church has not apostatized at a church level
on these issues. These individuals as far as they
are I am concerned they have apostatized. Don't
we have pastors that preach evolution? Must I
leave the church because there are people that
were conference presidents and union presidents
that say that uh you know evolution is the way
to go or the papacy has changed. Must I leave
my church? No. I'll wait till they are spat
out or they are converted and get their heads
right. That's my answer. Oh, beautiful. All
right. Well, we I guess this may be the final
question. Would you do an interview with Pastor
Tim Rosenberg? Ah, this is an interesting one.
We had him here before. Interesting guy. Yeah,
he's interesting when Daniel is interesting. All
right. There are lots of portions of overlap and
uh you know I will do interviews with people but I
I don't want to I don't want to debate the truth.
Uh that's what I uh debate is something that the
spirit of prophecy um does not speak favorably
about. I would like to state truth and someone
else can state the truth as they see it like we
just did. But we we didn't start a debate let's
say on what do you believe about the Holy Spirit
or what do you believe about this or that or the
other or evolution or this to me it's not an
issue of debate. I will state my case. You can
state your case and the and the audience can
choose. So if it's not in the form of a debate
but just a statement of what you believe then I
have no problem. I will I will reach out to Tim
if he's willing to have an open dialogue like we
like you'd had with dog Wilson when the way you
handled that was really done with you and and
also heritage of hope just open dialogue about
their the perspective on Daniel 11 and king of
the south king of the north interpretation. I
think that would be great. There are many issues
within this church where uh I don't believe that
it's absolutely salvational that you see it this
way or that way. And there are others which cannot
be compromised. You cannot compromise the three
angels messages. You cannot compromise the the
issue of the antichrist. You cannot compromise on
any of those. If you want to believe otherwise,
go for it. But you're not going to change my
mind. Yeah. Amen. Amen. Thank you for that. Yeah,
some stuff are not salvific in nature, so we
don't need to lose our head over that. Um,
can we talk a little bit about Clash of
Minds before we let you go? What are you
guys doing there? I I I've been watching
some of these episodes and it's it's a
lot of work you guys are doing. So, tell
us a little bit more about your ministry,
how you can get supported for your ministry and
some of the things that you got going on. Okay,
we are a totally nonprofit organization. Our uh
philosophy is to get the three angels messages
in all its forms out to the world. We try as far
as possible to make it available. We uh we rely
totally on donations and God is is gracious
and we've been able to do what we are doing.
We distribute Bibles. We have uh people that go
into unreached areas that go and bring the three
angels messages. We distribute literature from the
spirit of prophecy. So that's part of our ongoing
uh evangelistic outreach. Then of course we have
the various programs that we have what is truth
and uh what's up prof and then we have pastor
duply who is 92 years old and still going strong.
Some of these people I don't know they
carry on forever it seems to me. So yes
so our our mission is to reach the world with
the three angels messages. We also run a health
uh institute where we teach lifestyle. We also
have a school of evangelism only a one-mon course
crash course in what are the three angels messages
all about and that takes place twice a year.
And that's basically what we do. And if we have a
spare moment, then we'll do some public speaking,
camp meetings, evangelistic outreaches, things
like that. It's a very, very hectic program and
God has put together people that have a passion
and uh I'm very grateful for that. Martin,
for example, my own own son who had gone deep into
the world was playing in a heavy metal rock band.
He's now one of the speakers which shows that God
hears prayer. He's amazing. Hallelujah. And we
have Marlo who is a is a very very uh deep scholar
about the truth. And the nice thing about uh the
core is that we we don't have much variation in
terms of our theological thinking on that level
and on our on our lifestyles we are on one accord.
That doesn't mean that everybody is on the same
page in terms of everybody else but more or less
I think that the message we're trying to bring
across is a holistic one. But the core is bringing
the three angels messages to the world. Praise
God. Amen. I put a link in the chat for you guys
to go and support Clash of Minds Ministries and
the things that they are doing. That's very kind
of you. Thank you. Yeah. The one comment I want
to highlight the orange juice. There we go. He is
such a blessing to us SDA. Thank you, Walter Ry,
for your love for God and truth. It truly this
comment couldn't have been said better. Yeah,
thank you. That's very kind. Yeah, we absolutely
can see the power of the Holy Spirit just working
through you, through your life, and we are so
grateful that you came to join us today. Thank
you. This is powerful message. Thank you for
your graciousness. And there's over 700 people,
which is probably small in your personal world
of how many people you've spoke to. But for AMC,
that really shows the impact that you have on
people and their walk with God and the impact
that you have and how much they appreciate how
God exudes from your life and from your words and
the wisdom that God's poured into you. Yeah. So,
thank you. It's only 10 a.m., so we we managed to
get some of these people out of bed. It's not
I don't think it's anything special in us but
it's I think they come in here to hear what you
have to say because of the way your ministry has
blessed them. So I thank the Lord for what he's
done through you and uh the fruit is showing. So
I know there's been a lot of challenges there's
been some cancellation but you have also uh the
Lord has worked in the midst of all of it and it's
very obvious and we are one of them. I can say for
certain I'm one of them who has been tremendously
blessed by your content. Sometime when I'm trying
to make sense of the madness that's going on, I'm
like, "Absolutely. What is Clash of Minds? What
does Clash of Minds have to say?" You know, when I
go there and I'm like, "Thank you, Lord." Sometime
I take some of the thought into my own videos.
And so, cheat code everybody. Cheat code. So,
um, and and then kind of regurgitate that because
I I totally understand the nature of the gift
that God has given you and your research is
it's just massive. But even more than that,
I love your spirit. You tell the truth in
love even when it is offensive. I'm like,
but he's telling the truth though and he's not
angry about it. Unlike that man that was just
like, you know, repent of your sin. You call
to repentance, but I feel like when you say it,
it's said in such a way it makes me want to repent
instead of running away from God. And I love that
about you. You don't sugarcoat the truth and at
the same time the truth is always spoken in love.
And I appreciate that about you. Thank you.
truth is and nobody gets nobody gets baptized
into clash of minds. I believe the Lord has a
bride and the spirit and the bride say come and
uh I'm a seventh day Adventist and I always tell
the people you know what this the the wheat and
the tears grow together and if we think that it
is our job to weed out the tears uh it's not so
it's the writer with the inorn it was an angel
God will send his angels to weed out the tears so
that's not our job our job is to preach the truth
truth and leave that to God because I cannot read
all the motives of the heart and uh I don't know
if someone is going to be a kaiaphas or if he's
going to be an errand. Let me leave that to God.
But God has a movement and God has a church. And
I believe that that is the 7th Day Adventist
Church. And yes, it has its problems and yes,
it has a lot of tears, but it also has wheat.
May God May God bless your ministry. Thank
you so much. Thank you so much. Someone said,
"Preach to these dead bones." Professor Walter by
God has quickened our soul. Our soul with the
word of God live. Yes. Yes. There is hope.
There is hope. There is hope. Absolutely. No
doubt knowest. Uh man, thank you so much. I am
so blessed. And you know, would you please come
back? That's all I'm going to ask. Please come
back. We're going to give you a couple months. Uh
you know, we're going to give you but eventually
the emails will start being sent out by this by
this lovely wife. You will get you will get the
positive and the negative. And I don't mind that
at all because the Bible says, "Woe to you if all
men speak well of you." So, I'm so glad that there
are some that don't. It lets you know you must be
doing something right. Yeah. Yeah. All right.
Thank you so much. I really appreciate you. We
want to pray for uh Martin because he couldn't
join us today and we know we're not going to
be friends with that. There's some stuff going on.
Yes. We need to pray. Pray for him. Yeah. And tell
him we miss him. We we wanted to hear and I love
his gentle spirit. So, it's good to see you guys
working together. The Lord has given you uh what
was the friend that uh Martin Luther had? Yeah,
Meenon. The Lord has given you a mealon. Yeah, I I
think Martin is a little bit more fiery than Meon,
but uh we need that in the times that we are
living in. Yeah. We are thinking about him.
We got to be praying for him. usually one of those
next. Yeah. So, the good thing is I have a wife in
ministry. So, that that's my I'm a lender. Thank
you. All right. Well, uh we would like to have a
word of prayer for you and also for your ministry
as well. Thank you, Father. We just thank you so
much for the time we spend together to hear the
wisdom that you've given to your man servant and
thank you for his willingness to share and to
enlighten the minds of God's people. Father, we
pray not only for him, for his ministry, for his
health. We also want to pray for Martin that you
will bless him in his ministry as well. Strengthen
him in every areas of his life. You know what's
happening. We surrender this matter to you,
heavenly father. And Lord, we pray for Clash of
Minds as a ministry that you will continue to use
them in a very powerful way to reach the hearts of
God's people. Not only they are informing the
mind, but they are also inspiring the heart.
We pray that these ministries not only will um
teach us these things that are going on in our
time today but even more draw us closer to the
lamb of God who alone who alone takes away the
sins of the world. Bless uh professor Walter Vith
you know he has a busy schedule a lot of traveling
happening and he has a lot to do but father we
simply place them in the palms of your hands.
Bless the hearts of God's people those who are
able to listen to this conversation. May we take
what we've learned today and apply them in our
lives is our prayer. We ask it in Jesus name.
Amen. Amen. Amen. Thank you very much. And
professor, I'm going to ask you just to say
a final prayer. I know everyone online, including
myself, would be totally blessed if you just pray
a prayer of blessing for each one of us as we
continue to study and prepare for these times
that we're living in. Amen. Heavenly Father, I
want to thank you for ministries such as Advent
Media Connect and James and Andrea and everybody
who has at heart to bring the final message of
warning to a dying world. It's such a privilege
to serve you. It's not always easy. The winds are
often strong. The water rushes over the side of
the boat. And sometimes we do wonder whether you
are sleeping. But the the the beautiful part
about that story is immediately there were on
the other side that also happened on numerous
occasions. You can take us out of situations,
leave us in situations, but there are lessons
in all of these in all of these stories. And I
pray that we will internalize them. And who are we
that we shouldn't be subject to lessons as well?
Why should we be excluded from the honing and the
chisling that takes place outside the quarry? So
I I pray for these ministries and I pray for the
people involved and I pray that you will hue them
and square them so that they fit beautifully into
that temple that you are erecting that spiritual
house that will be standing forever and ever as
a monument of your sacrifice. Thank you, Lord,
for making us partakers of your great plan. And
may it come to a close in the climax of history
very soon is my prayer in Jesus' name. Amen. Amen.
Amen. Thank you so much, doctor. That was great.
Heat. Heat.
Heat.